the few times that i ever did was around
holidays because she was really big on
cards
so in my head i was like okay she's just
i'm making excuses for this woman saying
hey she's really
good at writing her feelings out as
opposed to like
saying her feelings so i said hey why
don't you write me a letter
say everything that you want to say you
know
but more so i also was saying something
along the lines of her like hey i need
you to take responsibility for this
relationship
with breakup i know how did that go i
promise
uh so i said i was like i was like did
you get a woman to take responsibility
we all want to know spoiler no
no um so i came back from the weekend
there and there it was essentially i
found this letter on
on my dresser and it was just the most
like
cliche dear john letter as if
she had just given it to a friend and
said hey just like tell this guy every
every guy in any 80s romance movie has
heard when he's like not the guy and
she's going to run off with like the
other dude and he's just the guy that
didn't make the cut
and so i was so angry for
weeks about this because i just asked
her to do one thing like
how could she after two and a half years
just act like this and
throw everything away like it meant
nothing and then when i started to learn
about this kind of stuff
and it's this idea of are you mad at the
sky for being blue like
are you mad at the ocean for being wet i
mean there's a passage in your book when
you talk about that
it's no when and once you accept it you
know what's really funny to me
it's like people think red pill guys are
bitter but you know that's sure
yeah that's when they start to lean into
the whole black pill narrative and
you know they go down that terrible
spiral
but blue pill guys are bitter because
their thinking isn't they don't know why
they're better though
could be like this is the way it should
be like everything i've been taught
about elevate her be less so she can be
more
and but here's the difference between a
guy that's like taking the red pill and
they can
you know see the code in the matrix
versus the blue pill guy that hasn't
the blue cup like the blue pill guy is
bitter but he doesn't know why
red pill guy that's gone down that
vicious spiral
gone into the black pill sort of you
know area they're bitter and they know
why
but they don't want to do anything about
it they want to hold on to that victim
mindset
yeah totally and i mean
that that's so so once guys realize
female nature
and it works with guys too and i've been
in situations
where you know you understand that
i've had this is a recent uh and this is
just a quick story this is a recent
situation they actually have this
actually happened like yesterday
uh i play in here and locally in new
york i play in like intramural softball
leagues people just get together and
they stick around on sundays and play
and i've got a couple of buddies that
play with me and
what's really common is after the games
like everybody just goes to the bar
and has a couple of drinks and she's a
good way of meeting people and so
you know there's this cute girl playing
catcher and every time i'd go off to bed
i'm
flirting with her and chatting with her
and this and that and the other and i
get her number after the game until i'm
gonna come meet them at the bar
afterwards and
it's me and a couple of buddies and so
we meet up with them and it's like a big
group
table of like 10 or 12. so it's not like
ideal like i'm sitting a couple of spots
away and she's
but we were texting and this sort of
thing and one of my friends like
my buddy got a seat like right across
from her and he knew i was texting her
and he knew i was like oh excited about
maybe trying to ask this girl out
and as the night goes on like he's
leaning in really close he's like really
like
into her and she's starting to give him
interest indicators and touching him on
the shoulder and stuff like that
and six months ago moth would have been
like
dude you knew i liked that girl like you
knew i wanted to ask her out like what
are you doing like you're
[ __ ] me and i'm like he's just a
dude that wants to get laid it's fine
and like
and i'm not gonna let some girl that i
met two hours ago
like it's a girl man i even text him
this morning i was like hey did you go
home with that chick or what
and he's like no i got a number blah
blah blah but and so it's really easy
for guys to
you know guys are naturally competitive
creatures like they're competing for
for women so and me if i didn't have
this
abundance mentality and you know
three or four girls that i'm that i'm
seeing or rotating in or spinning that i
could just go chat up any time i want
i could be i would be really pissed
about it and really like whatever like
you
like you blocked my shot or this and
that and the other so it's a scarcity
mindset you know most guys fall into
that trap right
like that one girl and i i worked up the
i worked up the courage to go and get
her number at the ball game and then my
buddy started talking already touched
her to cut her upper
yeah and they just fall apart it's like
dude you wouldn't care if you had
options
yeah and so i wouldn't care if you put
yourself first you know you wouldn't
care you just wouldn't
you